well hello everybody welcome back to
css3 in 30 days
today is day number 23 and we're going
to be building a css3 accordion this is
what I'm talking about over here
an accordion is simply grouping of
elements and content and typically how
an accordion would work is that when you
click on say a tab that content expands
and if you clicked on a different tab
that content expands and it contracts
the other or retracts the other content
now typically this would be built in
jQuery or JavaScript but the fun thing
about this is that this is built
exclusively in css3 now there is a
little bit of a limitation here and
perhaps I challenge you to find a way
around it
with exclusive css3 when you open an
accordion item if I click on this item
again it doesn't close it and that is
because of the limitation of using CSS
in this case perhaps that's not a big
issue for you if you want to leave all
of the content open at once perhaps
there's a different workaround but the
way that we build it today it's quite
simple and it will allow you to build an
accordion very quickly in your own
websites displaying content displaying
services or whatever it is that you want
to use for an accordion so let's jump in
and get started over here in my code
editor I have day number 23 css3
accordion opened up give yourself a
moment to download those and open it up
in your favorite code editor and then
open up your index and sandbox of CSS of
course as always final about CSS is
available for your reference and let me
show you the index.html first this is
the mark-up in our sandbox here under
the level for heading we have a div of
the class of accordion and then a div
with the class in within that of
accordion double underscore item and
then we have an a tag with an href that
that navigates to an anchor tab one and
then a class a couple classes in fact
for styling and then we have a div with
the idea of tab 1 and the class of
accordion content and then there's two
other identical setups just with tab 2
and tab 3 now what happens here is when
we click this this link it navigates the
browser down to this
so it's an anchor and then it navigates
it down to this div so this is looking
for tab 1 the idea of tab 1 it pops down
to tab 1 and you can see that when you
just click on the base mark up here so
if I click on accordion 1 it pops to
that content right there according to it
pops to that content according 3 pops to
that content and that's the default
functionality in the final version it
doesn't do that we're gonna be using
that as a way to animate and display
this content so that's how the markup is
set up let's jump into our sandbox and
get styling now a lot of this styling is
going to be just I guess cosmetic the
functionality of hiding and showing it
is actually quite simple and you'll see
that in a moment
but we're gonna make it look a little
bit better because why not
so let's style just accordion
position:relative display:block
background color we're gonna make it
white and then border:solid 1px ol and
then to go yo eyo eyo all right so now
we're gonna say accordion double
underscore item display:block and that
means we're styling this entire item
here so it's this whole piece so there's
the accordion or traps everything then
there's a Cardian item which wraps the
entire item within there and then
there's more elements so we're gonna
display that block we're gonna say a
Cordy in and then accordion content and
then we're gonna go display:block
padding:0 height this is important 0
we're hiding it and we're gonna say
overflow:hidden so we're hiding any of
the overflow because there will be an
overflow when we say height 0 the
elements going to contract the elements
gonna have 0 height but the text
should will be overflowing outside of
that element so we want to hide that
content when it overflows outside of its
height and then we're gonna say
transition we're just gonna transition
the height 0.5 seconds ease and we're
also gonna transition the padding at 0.3
seconds and linear because why not let's
just see what that does once we get to
it so if we save that and check it out
you can see now that we're starting to
show that you know where we're hiding
the content and we're starting to get
some base styles here so let's make it
look a bit nicer we're going to select
the accordion and then the accordion
content and the paragraphs within there
we're just going to give the whole
paragraph a padding of 20 pixels and
zero margin very simple we don't need to
review that style then we're going to
select the accordion the accordion
content and then target so what this
means is when we click on this a with
the target or the anchor whatever you
want to call it let's call it target of
tab 1 it's looking for this so this is
the target element of this once we click
here so we're going to style this when
that action is performed is essentially
what that's saying because if I were
just to style this it's just going to
style the content when I do this it's
actually going to match it once it's
been a target of that click and you'll
see how that works we're gonna say
height 150 pixels so a hard-coded height
so it's going to go to that height right
now it's at zero accordion content is
when we click that link and now it's
we're basically activating this the
selector the target it's going to
actually make that height 150 pixels and
because we have a transition on the
height it's going to animate down let's
just see if that works
so there we go i'm clicking on cording
one two and three and so really we just
made the accordion it's done that
functionality has is complete you can
see how quite quite simple that was
however i want to make this look nice
and use a few more minutes just to make
this a little bit more pretty so lets
style the accordion and then the
accordion trigger we're gonna say
text-decoration:none so that's the link
we're gonna remove that text decoration
so it doesn't really look like a link
we're gonna select the accordion and
then the accordion title
position:relative display:block margin:0
padding:0 color or background double
zero b3 b4 color white border:solid 1px
ol three seven nine double-a four let's
see what that looks like so far so
that's gonna be that whole title there
we go so we've got that teal color in
the background with a border but I want
to make it look a little bit more
three-dimensional in each of those
elements so we're gonna do that with
some box shadow so I'm gonna say box
shadow zero one pixels 0 rgba 255 255
255 and then 0.5 and then inset so save
that if I left it at that it would look
a little bit like this so we've got that
white highlight at the very top as if
there's a light source shining down from
the top angle but I also want more to it
I want to give a let me see here I want
to have a border on the bottom and
around it so there's actually gonna be
quite a bit more here so let's put a
comma here you can add more box shadows
within the same value within the
saying after the property you can add
multiple values zero negative one pixels
0 rgba 255 255 255 and 0.1 and also
inset so that will look a little bit
like this well you can't even really see
it let's just make it a hard-coded like
yellow so you can see where that is so
down here we're going to have another
highlight down at the bottom so let's
change it back to 255 and and if I made
it a little bit more visible you'd see
the white line at the bottom now we
don't really like that I want it more
subtle so maybe let's try something like
I think 0.1 is good
super super subtle it just adds a little
bit of depth to it a little bit of a
highlight at the bottom remember the
light source looks like it's coming from
the top so I don't want to confuse your
eyes and have multiple light sources I
guess it doesn't matter it's up to you
now I'm gonna say another comma 0 4
pixels 0 and then 3 3 889 4 that's gonna
be a shadow on the outside at the bottom
of the title there so it's a thick
darker line and now the reason why we
did this previous one this gentle
highlight is to give a little bit of
depth to that thick shadow on the bottom
so it looks like it's a box coming out
and you can see if I mean that just a
little bit lighter you could see that
line there now if that doesn't look as
good so I kind of still like my original
decision of 0.1 super subtle
cool all right now the next one we're
gonna do one more box shadow 0 4 pixels
2 pixels rgba 0 0 0 0.5 and that was
going to give us a shout out around the
element altogether so each of them kind
of just pop now we're going to do is
when we hover there's more to it here so
we're gonna say accordion accordion
double underscore title and then hover
we're gonna say background color is
going to be o BB f c0 that will look a
little bit like this so it just
highlights a little bit nice usability
little feature there now we're gonna do
one last thing just a couple more styles
here I want an arrow at the far right
hand side now instead of going into
Photoshop and creating one and then
creating a retina version of it and all
that sort of stuff we just want this
done in CSS we want it done quickly and
we're just going to use a convention
that we've already used in past videos
of using borders to create triangle okay
so let's say accordion and then
accordion title after and now we're
gonna say position absolute of course a
needs to be content empty string we're
gonna give it a let's see rights of 20
pixels so in 20 pixels from the right
the width is going to be 7 pixels height
7 pixels so a pretty small arrow border
left 2 pixels on solid 2 pixels white
border-bottom:solid 2 pixels white
let's see what that looks like so far
okay so we've just got the left side the
left border and the bottom border of a
square now as you can see all we need to
do is just rotate it a little bit 45
degrees and then position it a little
bit down in the center vertically we're
just going to say transform and rotate
and negative 45 degrees that will bring
it counterclockwise that's right that's
what we want save that there we go that
looks amazing and now we need that to be
down further so we're gonna use the
we're gonna go top so up here in your
rights we're gonna say top if I said 50%
it's going to be too far because it's
50% from the top of the border which is
actually like right up here so this
whole thing is about this size so it's
actually 50% from I think it looks like
it's so 2% from there yes so do percent
from there actually and we need it up
probably about 7 maybe let's try let's
do this calc because we want 50% and a
pixel value so let's try that - 7 pixels
so it looks like it's too far up so I
want to bring it down just a bit more so
we'll say 5 pixels that looks centered
to me that's it there's our css3
accordion right there and now it should
work just fine
there's our css3 accordion like I said a
lot of this was cosmetic we're just
playing around with the styles but
that's what CSS is for after all the
functionality of displaying the content
using that target selector was quite
simple it's just a few lines of CSS and
that's it to create a css3 accordion I
hope this gave you some ideas for your
own websites applications and so on and
so forth thanks for joining me in day
number 23 and tight day number 24 is
coming
Jeff tomorrow by now
[Music]